welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today you know we have a very
real problem of money and politics there
are too many people in this country
unless of course you happen to be an
elected official that would disagree
with that I mean there's a lot of
Republicans Democrats and everything in
between that agree that corporate money
that PAC money is a major problem here
in the United States well here's the
thing though it's actually a little bit
worse than what we thought because it's
bad enough that politicians can get
endless money from whichever corporation
they want and now some of them don't
even have to report where the money's
coming from what's even worse is that
politicians have realized that with
nobody looking over their shoulder and
with money classified as free speech
they can just use all this money as
their own personal piggy bank in the
last few days alone stories have emerged
of people like Devon Nunez and Rand Paul
using their PAC money again as their own
piggy bank now before we get into that
story let me explain here the law is
very clear these politicians are not
allowed to use any of their PAC money
even if that money is considered free
speech on anything other than
campaigning fundraising and if they
would like they can give it to another
person's PAC they cannot spend it on
anything personal and I tell you that to
tell you this according to the Fresno
Bee here
Devin Nunez spent nearly fifteen
thousand dollars on tickets to the
Boston Celtics basketball team as well
as winery tours and lavish trips to Las
Vegas his PAC spent about forty two
thousand seven hundred and forty one
dollars in the last five years on
catering site rentals hotels and meals
in Las Vegas now known as is a
congressman from the state of California
so we could pretty much guarantee that
spending 42
thousand dollars in Las Vegas that's not
exactly a reelection campaign is it um
most recent instance of this was on
March 9th of this year when this PAC
spent seven thousand two hundred and
twenty nine dollars at seven different
restaurants and hotels in Las Vegas
his PACs expenditures also included
nearly five thousand dollars on six
different winery tours in Paso Robles
and Santa Margarita which are both
outside his district in California and
he spent five thousand dollars at Gold
Coast limousine on the same day that he
was doing these winery tours he also had
a hotel charge for four thousand four
hundred and nine dollars at sea venture
which is a hotel that is 20 miles away
from his district but here's the thing
he listed all of these as fundraising
expenses fundraising so he had to go
spend money to make money again
hundred percent this is against the
rules this is not legal for them to do
this but he did it and because there is
no oversight there is no one willing to
look over their shoulders on any of the
House Ethics committees or House Finance
Committee's that are supposed to be in
charge of this nobody wants to look over
each other over shoulders because it's
pretty obvious that all of them are
doing this let's go to Rand Paul Rand
Paul the the fiscally conservative slash
libertarian guy who hates any and all
wasteful spending he's using his
personal PAC here reinventing a new
direction is the name of it which is I
don't even want to get into the grammar
of reinventing a new direction
it's whatever Paul spent eleven thousand
and forty three dollars at restaurants
in Italy and Malta last year the man who
hates any kind of spending spend eleven
thousand dollars on meals alone in the
Mediterranean he spent four thousand
four hundred and ninety two dollars on
limo services in Rome he spent one
thousand
and four dollars on an upscale hotel in
Athens he also spent 1575 dollars at
restaurant and Trump Hotel here's the
thing how is any of that fundraising how
is any of that campaigning this is Rand
Paul using his donors money to go out
there and live the high life and go on
this beautiful Mediterranean vacation
that most Americans would love to go on
but will never be able to afford it
because we're not corrupt like these
Republican and most likely Democratic
politicians are this is insanity but
this is what happens when you have a
corrupt Supreme Court that tells us that
money is free speech if money were
actually free speech as the Supreme
Court tells us in citizens united and
McCutcheon if money were free speech
then wouldn't it be that those without
money don't have speech it's that simple
it's that simple and that is why money
can't be free speech if money is free
speech which we're all entitled to then
wouldn't we all be entitled to the same
amount of money there's no restrictions
on or no limits on how much free speech
you get but there is limits on what kind
of money you can get from the government
itself whether it's Medicaid Medicare
Social Security food stamps or just
straight-up tax returns if you want to
call money free speech then you have to
ensure that everybody has the same
amount of speech and a good lawyer
arguing that when citizens united was in
front of the court could have put an end
to this before any of it even started